haz la resta expresa la respuesta como
una expresión racional simplificada e
indica el dominio muy bien aquí tenemos
una resta de expresiones racionales y
para realizar la resta necesitamos un
denominador común justo como le hacíamos
cuando aprendimos a restar fracciones
bueno pues para encontrar ese
denominador común una buena idea es
factorizar ambos denominadores y
asegurarnos de encontrar un término que
tenga todos los factores bueno este
denominador de aquí ya está factor izado
es simplemente una más 2 vamos con este
de acá tenemos un a cuadrada más 4 a más
4 hay que encontrar dos números que
multiplicados del 4 y que sumado sobre
estados de 4 bueno pues 2 y 2 funciona
si aquí ponemos además 2 y lo
multiplicamos por a más 2 a 2
entonces además dos programas 12 es esta
expresión aquí tenemos dos a con otros
dos a es igual a 4 a 2 por 2 es 4 y aquí
está el a cuadrada bueno no tenemos que
además 2 por 2 pues claramente se divide
asimismo verdad cualquier cosa se divide
misma salvo quizás 0 pero bueno este
término de aquí es divisible entre sí
mismo entonces es múltiplo de a más dos
programas 2 pero si aquí ponemos y aquí
tenemos a más 2 pues a más dos programas
2 también es múltiplo de a más 2
entonces esto quiere decir que este
término es justo el mínimo común
múltiplo de este denominador y este
denominador así que lo hace un muy buen
denominador común entonces déjame déjame
poner que esto es igual a vamos a poner
a esto como denominador común entonces
voy a copiar este término es igual a
menos 2 entre a más 2 que lo voy a poner
aquí a menos 2 entre a más 2 pero ahora
necesitamos cambiar el denominador a
además 2 por a más 2 y para hacer eso
voy a multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por a más 2 equipo y voy a
poner programas 2 y arriba también voy a
multiplicar por a más 2 para no alterar
la expresión pero sin modificar el
denominador
aquí estamos suponiendo que a más dos es
distinto de cero o sea que a es distinto
es distinto de menos dos y esto de aquí
lo necesitamos asumir desde el principio
porque si no aquí estaríamos dividiendo
entre cero de esta forma nuestro dominio
va a ser todas las que sean distintas de
menos dos bueno entonces vamos a seguir
con esta expresión de acá aquí ya
tenemos este denominador común ahorita
desarrollamos déjame copiar este término
entonces ahí hay que restar a menos tres
a menos tres dividido entre lo voy a
poner factor izado para que después sea
más fácil simplificar a más 2 x a más 2
muy bien ahora vamos a simplificar esto
vamos a desarrollar aquí el numerador y
luego realizamos la resta entonces aquí
tenemos a menos 2 x a más 2 podríamos
realizar las operaciones pero seguro ya
lo identificaste como una diferencia de
cuadrados
aquí quedaría a cuadrada menos 2 al
cuadrado o sea a cuadrada a cuadrada
menos 4 esto es igual a cuadrada menos 4
y en el denominador nos queda a más 2 lo
voy a poner en color amarillo a más 2 x
a más 2 ya eso debemos restar déjame
alargar esta esta línea lo voy a poner
con color rosa para que siga teniendo
sentido el color y eso tenemos que
restarle a menos 3 hay que tener cuidado
restar a menos 3 es sumar cada uno de
estos multiplicados por menos 1 entonces
hay que restar a y sumar 3 muy bien y
esto que es igual esto es igual a a
cuadrada
a cuadrada - a menos a y luego tenemos
que sumar 3 y restar 4 o sea restar 1 y
eso lo dividimos entre a más dos
programas 2 que lo voy a poner como a
más 2 elevado al cuadrado
y aquí podrías preguntarte si esto se
puede simplificar todavía más en caso de
que se pudiera simplificar tendríamos
que factorizar el numerador y
encontraron a más 2 pero no lo vamos a
encontrar porque si hubiera un a más 2
este término quedaría múltiplo de 2 como
no es múltiplo de 2 no hay un a más 2 en
el numerador y por lo tanto esto ya es
la expresión simplificada así que la
respuesta sería a cuadrada menos a menos
1 entre a más 2 al cuadrado y el dominio
son aquellas aquellos valores de a que
sean distintos distintos de menos 2 muy
bien esto de aquí sería la respuesta